won't see the inside of a courtroom
anytime soon
so without non-judicial steps to impose
consequences on the israel islamic
republic
there will likely be no justice for ms
leginajad
and her family and why should tehran
think twice about trying again
sadly this has a familiar ring to it
flagrant disregard for international law
is certainly not a new addition
to tehran's playbook
remember back in 2011 iranian
intelligence was caught up in a plot to
murder the ambassador of saudi arabia to
the united states
by blowing up a restaurant right here in
washington
one of the iranian officials indicted in
that case
is actually still at large
of course extra judicial activities on
american soil aren't the only bits of
iranian behavior
that read like old news
miss alina jad has been vocally
reminding us
that iran's disgusting disregard for
human rights is not unique
to american soil obviously it's felt in
iran itself and throughout the middle
east
this spring the skies over israel were
filled with reminders
of iran's long-standing support for
terrorist groups
like hamas and hezbollah
battlefields in syria and southern
arabian peninsula testified to the
strength
of iran's proxies and just this year on
president biden's watch
we've seen a surge a surge in attacks on
u.s
interests and facilities in iraq
not seen since the height of our
military presence
in that country so
history continues to repeat itself in
tehran
and unfortunately the biden
administration appears keen
keen to follow a familiar playbook
of its own inexplicably the white house
response to iran's latest troublemaking
now listen to this has been to consider
lifting sanctions
and offering new concessions to produce
a new nuclear deal
mr president iran just tried to kidnap
an american
right here in america this is not the
occasion to desperately
reward bad behavior
it's time to work even more closely with
our allies and partners in the regions
to stir it down
i suggest that's the quorum caller small
[Music]
one
so
so
mr president the republican went mr
president of the senate in a quorum call
i would ask unanimous consent that the
quorum call
be lifted without objection mr president
last week
i came down to the floor to discuss how
the defund the police movement has
contributed
to the surging crime that we see around
the country
as i noted the democrat party bears a
substantial degree of responsibility for
the situation we find ourselves in
because this is a party that either
actively contributed to defund the
police rhetoric or implicitly endorsed
it largely
by staying silent now however democrats
have come to realize that attacking the
police
and the sharp spike in crime could hurt
their electoral
chances next year and so the president
and other democrat leaders
have all of a sudden announced their
concern about rising crime rates
but as i said last week they're still
trying to have their cake and eat it too
because missing from their messaging is
any real condemnation
of defund the police rhetoric and the
toll it's taken on our cities and police
departments
and their plans for confronting the
surge in crime are long on punishing gun
dealers
and gun manufacturers and short on going
after those actually committing crimes
it's typical of democrats for whom
fighting crime seems to involve
controlling guns
specifically guns owned by law abiding
gun owners
more than it involves controlling
criminals
what democrats should be doing is
training their attention on violent
offenders
traffickers and gangs in illegal
straw purchases not finding ways to
saddle
law-abiding gun owners with burdensome
new regulations
because because it is not law-abiding
gun owners who are responsible for most
of the gun crimes in this country
the majority of gun crimes mr president
are committed by individuals who
obtained
their guns illegally
illegally which is why fighting this
crime should involve improving
enforcement of our laws and increasing
prosecution of those who violate them
not creating new laws
that will only serve to further burden
the constitutionally guaranteed second
amendment rights
of law-abiding individuals unfortunately
mr president as i said democrats are
following their usual playback
playbook during their this recent crime
surge
which they seem to see as a convenient
excuse for pushing some of their gun
control priorities
the president recently delivered remarks
on crime
and the first priority that he discussed
at length was going after
federally licensed firearm dealers
that's right firearm dealers
mr president while we can all agree that
firearms dealers who
violate the law should be punished the
rogue
gun dealers that the president refers to
are only responsible for a tiny
fraction of the guns being used in
crimes
going after gun dealers is one of your
top law enforcement priorities and not
going to do much to stem the illegal
flow of weapons
or their use in crimes enforcement
dollars and
enforcement personnel are not endless
mr president and you can waste a lot of
money
and a lot of man-hours conducting checks
of law-abiding gun dealers while
criminals continue to use their
illegally obtained weapons
unchecked mr president nowhere
are president biden's priorities more
clear than in his choice of nominee to
lead
the atf which is the bureau of alcohol
tobacco firearms
and explosives david shipman
would come to the atf directly from an
organization where he has spent
the past five years as a gun control
advocate
he's well known for his at times extreme
views
on gun control and restricting the
second amendment including
his support for banning probably the
most popular rifle in the united states
he supports a so-called assault
weapons ban which usually refers to
banning certain guns for their
accessories
and their appearance of lethality but
alarmingly
he could not give a clear representation
of how he would define such a policy
in his confirmation hearing equally as
troubling as mr chipman's clear disdain
for gun owners
he claimed that most individuals with
concealed carry permits
are either untrained or irresponsible
during the pandemic he mocked
law-abiding gun owners and
condescendingly said
that first-time gun owners should put
their guns away in their cabinets
behind the beef jerky behind the beef
jerky that they presumably been saving
for the apocalypse
and only take out the weapons if quote
the zombies start to appear end quote
mr president i appreciate mr chipman's
long service as an atf special agent
but i have serious concerns
that as the head of the atf he would
spend more time
going after a law abiding gun owners
than actual criminals
the fact that he spent years as a gun
control advocate gives us
pretty strong indication of what his
priorities are likely to be if he ends
up heading this bureau
although mr chipman couldn't make new
gun laws
as head of the atf he would certainly i
should say he could certainly have a
hand
in writing a whole lot of new
regulations
regulations that could end up
substantially burdening americans
second amendment rights atf has already
gotten
underway with the biden gun control
agenda with proposed rules against
firearm
parts kits often used
by hobbyists and widely used stabilizing
braces often referred to as pistol
braces first
designed to help a disabled veteran
safely fire a weapon these regulations
would turn
millions of legal gun owners into
potential criminals and david chipman
would be in charge
of seeing them through moreover his
demeaning attitude
toward gun owners should also disqualify
him from the atf position an individual
who regards law-abiding gun-owning
americans as a bunch of
untrained and irresponsible doomsday
preppers
waiting for the zombie apocalypse
has no business no business
leading a gun enforcement agency mr
president the president the vice
president and mr chipman may not like it
but the plain language of the bill of
rights clearly guarantees
the right of law-abiding americans owned
firearms
and that right like every other
right guaranteed by our constitution
must be respected and protected
and those who exercise their second
amendment rights deserve to be respected
as well
i do not believe we can rely on mr
chipman to respect our second amendment
rights
or the americans who exercise them which
is why i cannot vote to confirm him as
director
of the atf and i encourage supporters
of the second amendment on both sides of
the aisle
to oppose his nomination law-abiding
gun-owning americans deserve better than
mr chipman
to head the atf mr president i yield the
floor
[Music]
mr president senator from washington
thank you mr president
you know this pandemic has made it
clearer than ever that our economy
is working great for those at the very
top
but not for our workers saturday
actually marks the 12th
anniversary of the last time that we
raised our federal minimum wage
12 years that's unacceptable and our
workers really deserve better
no one working 40 hours a week should be
making wages
so low their families living in poverty
and they can't even afford to pay
for even their most basic needs it's
past
time that we finally give workers who
are the backbone of our economy and have
kept us going through this pandemic
a hard-earned and much-deserved raise
and another important step the senate
can take to build back an economy that's
stronger
and fairer and works for everyone is to
ensure that
agencies like the national labor
relations board
work effectively and protect workers
rights
jennifer abruzzo is the type of
dedicated public servant
who will make sure the nlrb is enforcing
the law
and protecting the rights of workers and
i urge all of our colleagues to join me
in voting to confirm her
as general counsel of the nlrb
she has dedicated her career to
upholding the law and protecting workers
from
unfair treatment she's won victories
against companies that attempted to
undermine workers right to organize and
call for better wages
and she has 23 years of experience at
the nlrb
including her time serving as acting
general counsel
the role she is now nominated to phil
it's clear she has the right experience
qualifications
and values for the job and we need her
to be able to get to work
right away because we have seen seven
years of un
we have seen years of unprecedented
republican obstruction
obstruction of the nlrb nominees there's
been an empty democratic seat on the
nlrb for nearly
three years and there wasn't a single
democrat on the board
from late 2019 until mid 2020
that obstruction tipped the scales of
justice
in favor of big corporations and workers
have suffered the consequences
when workers stand together to form a
union it is the nlrb
that makes sure the election is fair if
a worker is fired or unfairly punished
because they want to join or form a
union the nlrb is tasked with protecting
their rights
and if companies refuse to negotiate
fairly
with unions fighting for higher wages
and better benefits or
a secure retirement or safer working
conditions
it is the nlrb that protects unions and
union workers
who have helped build our country's
middle class
working families simply cannot afford an
nlrb
that fails to protect workers rights
when they are threatened
so we've got to confirm nominees like
jennifer abruzzo
who will protect workers rights and make
sure their voices are heard
if we're serious about building back a
stronger
fairer economy if we're serious about
standing with working families
then we need to confirm jennifer abruzzo
as jennifer general counsel of the nlrb
and then get to work increasing our
federal minimum wage
thank you mr president i yield the floor
colorado
oh i apologize
[Music]
11 30 mr president
i ask unanimous consent that the vote
scheduled to occur at 11 30
begin immediately
under the previous order the clerk will
report
the nomination
nomination national labor relations
board
jennifer ann abruzzo of new york to be
general counsel
questions on the nominations
miss baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker mr boseman
mr brawn mr brown mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito
mr cardin mr carper mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins mr coons
mr cornyn miss cortez masto mr cotton mr
kramer mr crapo
mr cruz mr danes miss duckworth mr
durbin miss ernst mrs feinstein mrs
fisher
mrs gillibrand mr graham mr grassley mr
hagerty
miss hassan mr hawley mr heinrich mr
hickenlooper miss
hirono mr hoeven mrs hyde smith mr
inhofe mr johnson mr kane mr kelly mr
kennedy mr
king ms klobuchar mr langford mr leahy
mr lee mr luhan
uh
so
islamists
[Music]
[Music]
do
um
mr mansion
[Music]
mr markey
mr marshall
[Music]
uh
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr markley
mr moran
murkowski
miss murkowski
mr murphy
mrs murray
yeah mr ossoff
mr bradia
mr paul
mr peters
mr portman
[Music]
mr reed
mr risch
mr romney
miss rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
[Music]
okay
so
mr sanders mr sass
mr schatz mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith
ms stabenow mr sullivan
mr tester mr thune
mr tillis mr toomey
mr tuberville mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock
ms warren mr whitehouse
mr wicker mr wyden
mr
over
young
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
you
blue
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
oh
history
good
oh
so
so
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin bennett can't well casey
feinstein hassan king klobuchar
leahy lujan manchin
marky merkley murphy murray
padilla shots schumer shaheen
smith white house wyden
voting in the negative blackburn
blunt cassidy collins cornyn
ernst graham grassley hovind
langford lee lummus
romney rounds sass
scott of florida tillis tuberville
wicker young gillibrand mrs gillibrand
aye mr warnock mr warnock aye mr van
hollen mr van hollen aye
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal aye mr
johnson mr johnson
no
mr ossoff mr ostoff i mr tester
mr tester i
mr reed mr reed aye
mr brown mr brown aye mr toomey
mr toomey no
miss warren miss warren i
mr cardin mr cardin i'm miss crapo
mr crapo no mr peters mr peters
i
thank you sir
[Music]
mr roano mrono i
[Music]
this
[Music]
foreign
mr inhofe mr imhof now
[Music]
[Music]
alright
uh
this one goes in miss rose and i
stabbed stabbing out i
miss markowski miss markowski now
mr side smith mrs hyde smith
no mrs capito mrs capito
no mrs fisher miss fisher
no
[Music]
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
mr durbin mr durbin
i mr cotton mr cotton
no mr barrasso mr barrasso
no
[Music]
mr kane mr kane i
[Music]
this is duckworth miss duckworth i
[Music]
mr cruz mr cruz
no
mr paul mr paul no
mr sanders mr sanders
i
mr boseman mr boseman no
mr burr mr burr no
mr marshall mr marshall
no mr kelly mr kelly
i
mr thune mr thune
now
so
mr coons mr coons aye mr shelby mr
shelby now
mr rubio mr rubio no
mr braun mr braun no
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper i
so
mr warner mr warner aye
mr menendez mr menendez aye
mr moran mr moran no
[Music]
so
mr haggerty mr hagerty no
mr booker mr booker aye mr kennedy mr
kennedy
now
miss cortes masto miss cortez masto
oh you're here for john mr carper mr
carper
i
mr kramer mr kramer now
mr hawley mr hall now
mr fresh mr rish now
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
[Music]
no
mr danes mr danes now
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
i
mr portman mr portman now
so
down
mr scott mr scott of south carolina
[Music]
now
this
yes
mr heinrich mr heinrich i
[Music]
you
foreign
foreign
oh
hey
yes
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so
much
mm-hmm
just
on this vote the a's are 50 the nays are
50.
the senate being equally divided the
vice president votes in the affirmative
and the nomination is confirmed under
the provision
of the previous order the motion to
reconsider is considered made and laid
upon the table
and the president will immediately be
notified of the senate's action
the clerk will report the motion to
invoke cloture
clerks your mission we the undersigned
senators in accordance with the
provisions of rule 22 the standing rules
of the senate do hereby move the brain
to a closed debate on the nomination of
executive calendar number 142 bonnie d
jenkins of new york
to be under secretary of state for arms
control and international security
signed by 17 senators
by unanimous consent the mandatory
quorum call has been
waived the question is is it the sense
of the senate that debate on the
nomination of
bonnie d jenkins of new york to be under
secretary of state for arms control and
international security
shall be brought to a close the yeas and
nays are mandatory under the rule
the clerk will call the roll ms baldwin
mr barrasso
mr bennett
yes i did thank you
i trust you
thank you
i got you thank you
i got you got you
thank you
this is blackburn
mr blumenthal mr blunt
thank you thank you
mr braun mr brown
mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito
mr cardin mr carper
mr casey mr cassidy
miss collins
mr coons
mr cornyn
ms cortez masto mr cotton
mr kramer
okay
mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes who's duckworth
mr durbin ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher this is gillibrand
mr graham mr grassley
mr hagerty ms hassan
mr hawley mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper miss hirono
mr hoeven mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson mr kane mr kelly
mr kennedy mr king
[Music]
miss klobuchar mr lankford mr leahy
mr lee mr luhan
ms llamas mr mansion
mr markey mr marshall
mr mcconnell mr menendez
mr merkley mr moran
miss murkowski mr murphy
mrs murray mr ossoff
mr padilla bless you mr paul
mr peters mr portman mr reed
mr rish mr romney ms rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio mr sanders mr sass
mr schatz
mr schumer mr scott of florida mr scott
of south carolina
mrs shaheen mr
shelby miss cinema
miss smith miss stabenow mr sullivan
mr tester mr thune
mr tillis mr toomey
mr tuberville mr van hollen mr warner
mr warnock miss warren mr whitehouse
mr wicker mr wyden
mr young
oops senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin bennett blumenthal
cantwell cardin casey
collins cortes masto duckworth
hassan heinrich hickenlooper kane
kelly klobuchar lujan mansion
marky murphy murray ossoff
paul rosen sanders smith
stabenow warnock warren and
white house mr peter's eye
senators voting in the negative braun
burr capitao cramer fisher
graham inhofe kennedy lankford
moran portman risch
romney rubio scott of south carolina
sullivan tillis tuberville and wicker
oh i'm sorry mr shahzad
[Music]
okay
mrs hyde smith no
[Music]
mr merkley
[Music]
[Music]
this mr barrasso
no
mr cornyn no
mr boseman now
so
[ __ ]
mr haggerty no
mr booker i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
all right put it in the chat